In the last question of
the previous section,
we saw that if you drive your
car 150 miles in three hours,
you can describe that with a rate
of 150 miles over three hours.
This rate simplifies into 50 miles
over one hour or 50 miles per hour.
This version of the rate is
what's known as a unit rate.
The reason this is a unit rate, we
have this uni in here which means one,
is because a unit rate is any rate where
the value of the denominator is 1.
These rates can be super useful,
primarily because
they're easy to compare.
Let's start with a simple question.
Rafael drives his car
at 64 miles an hour and
Anastasia drives at 62 miles per hour.
Who drives faster, Rafael or Anastasia?
This is not a trick question.